[Music]
in this video you'll learn how to
quickly adopt Google cloud platform
services with springboard framework
using spring cloud GCP GCP engineers
have been working closely with the
spring teams to produce idiomatic
integrations for many of our HTTP
services let's see how you can use cloud
spinner advocated tracing to cloud trace
sent logs to cloud logging with a spring
boot application first create a new
application using spring initializer at
start spring dial in the bottom you can
add dependencies to add capabilities to
your application add GCP support
generate the application and open it in
your favorite IDE you can use spring
data with cloud spanner so you can take
advantage of spring data features such
as object relational mapping crowd
repository inventing and auditing first
add the spring cloud gcpd cloudspinner
starter
create a POJO for object relational
mapping annotate the POJO with
cloudspinner invitations to configure a
table mapping and primary keys rather
than creating your own data access
object you can use spring data's
repository to automatically generate and
implement crud operations to cloud
spanner in application that properties
configure the cloud spanner instance ID
and database ID to connect to we can
then use the repository for basic crud
operations but you can also enhance the
repository with additional finder
methods or custom queries spring data
will automatically infer the query from
the name of the method or use the query
that you provide using the query
annotation finally rather than creating
your own rest controller by hand you can
also use spring data rest repository to
automatically create and expose a
restful service that can perform crowd
operations against the cloud spanner
database
it's important to understand the
topology of your distributed system you
can accomplish this through the use of
distributed tracing you can use sprinkle
TCP tray starter to add the Jubilee
tracing capability to your service it
uses sprinkler fluid underneath so it's
native to spring both applications and
they will automatically capture and
propagate the trace ID the Spain ID and
they will automatically configured
spring cloud smooth to send traces to
cloud trace by default
sprinkle salute will only simple in
report 10% of the requests you can
adjust the simply improbability for this
demo were adjusted to 100% and this is
only takes two a discipline tracing to
send traces to call trace similarly to
send log messages to cloud logging
simply add the sprinklers ECP logging
starter then configure the standard law
by configuration to use cloud logging
offenders there are two opinions you can
use if you are running on premise you
can send log entries to the API or if
you're running in gke you can use the
JSON on Pender to produce JSON format
login trees that's understood by GAE in
both cases you do not need to change any
code simply use the existing appenders
and most importantly the trace context
information will be automatically added
to the log entry so that later you can
correlate the trace graph with the
corresponding log messages let's go take
a look in the trace console we can
clearly see the trace associated with
the request but also its subsequent
calls
check the show logs checkbox and the
related bulk messages are also displayed
with sprinkle gzp you can quickly create
services or migrate existing services to
utilize GCP you can use spring data with
cloud spanner fire store and data store
you can add the sugar the tracing and
centralized logging without adding
custom code and there's so much more
[Music]